well you see typically though
politicians are not are not in our scope
I mean we really concentrate on
celebrities and but we don't really
enlarge our group of celebrities to
include politicians our readers not
coming to start to read about
politicians now if you had you know jf
JFK jr. was still alive and he ran for
politics I think that would be a little
different story because he is a
celebrity however I don't think that our
readers view any of the particular any
of the political candidates right now as
being in that as as being in that vein
or being members of the celebrity pack
so the tabloids I should say the
Enquirer really as part of its DNA has
always covered politicians and I'm sure
that as the as the campaign season heats
up and that you know they'll probably
get more
you